[موسيقى]
هو نوع من الخطاب الجديد في الخطابات
الاسلام السياسي كانوا يعرف باسم الدعاه
الجدد الدعاه الجدد يستخدمون اساليب وطرق
ليست معهوده
لدى الفقهاء التقليديين فهم اول
امرهم يعني يتقصدون السياسه في كل طرحهم
ويحومون حول السياسه الامر الاخر انهم
بداوا يقراون في علوم جديده
علوم الانا البيئي وعلوم التطوير الذات
وعلوم صنع القيادات وعلوم
مختلفه هو يطبقونها فيما يطرحون
[موسيقى]
هو ما في شك انهم قدموا خطابا جديدا لانهم
ليسوا فقراء تقليديين لا علاقه لا لكثير
منهم بالفقه التقليدي ولكن الشعار الاسلام
هو شعار سياسي يستخدمونه للوصول الى
اهدافهم واهدافهم صريحه سيطره على الحكم
الوصول الى السلطه بالسلم بالقوه بالثورات
بالقتال بالعنف لا يختلف طارق السويدان عن
اسامه بن لادن لا يختلف حسن البنا عن
البغدادي الخلاف بينهم فقط في الاساليب او
التكتيكات المتبعه للوصول الى هذا الهدف
[موسيقى]
من امثال
سلمان العوده وسفر الحوالي ثم جاء بعدهم
طارق السويدان وعمر خالد
وعده نماذج وامثله اخرى وهم هكذا الذي
يقرا تاريخ هذه الجماعات يعرف انها تطور
نفسها في كل مرحله بما يتوائم معها واليوم
ايضا لديهم اليات جديده وافكار جديده
لتطوير طروحاتهم لتتوائم مع المرحله
[موسيقى]